[Music]
a rare sound in afghanistan
[Music]
a musician and driver akhtar has lived
in a refugee camp since his childhood
he's among the more than three million
people displaced in afghanistan
before it was good but now life just
passes us by before we could find some
food for our children but the change in
government means there is no work now a
year ago tens of thousands of people
headed for the borders as provinces fell
to the taliban
many in kabul rushed to the airport as
the western-backed government collapsed
after taking refuge abroad ashraf
ghani's denied that he escaped with
suitcases full of cash
more than a hundred thousand people left
during the abrupt withdrawal of foreign
forces
the economy collapsed and the u.s rose
billions of dollars of foreign reserves
the u.s nato alliance spent an estimated
300 million dollars a day every day for
two decades but basics such as roads
schools hospitals are either
non-existent or in poor shape since the
taliban took over that money has stopped
coming in
and thousands of professionals have left
human rights watch has accused the
taliban of a long list of abuses
restricting the rights of women and
girls suppressing media freedom and
detaining torturing and executing
critics and perceived opponents
all allegations the taliban denies
in some other areas things are good
we're trying to improve but we should
also take into account the problems of
the coronavirus the suspension of
foreign aid the freezing of money the
problems in banking the drought all of
these together have increased the
problems for the people of afghanistan
for those who've left life's not easy
more than half the 20 000 afghans who
reach the uk are still in temporary
accommodation there's a lack of
prospects abroad and many face
harassment and the threat of detention
i lost everything including my
restaurant i planned to go to europe so
i went to turkey unfortunately they
captured us and deported us to iran
thank god now we are in our homeland and
i will never go anywhere else
in a year security has improved but
poverty and desperation have increased
and while the taliban seeks
international recognition there are some
concessions it seems unwilling to
down to make
[Music]